[Applaudissements]
tu es le président et voici quelques
jours la semaine dernière avec le groupe
d'amitié France Arménie du Sénat nous
nous sommes rendus à Erevan avec notre
collègue son président Gilbert Luc de
vinasse nous avons effectué ce
déplacement
alors que
l'Azerbaïdjan se livrait à sa énième
attaque contre le peuple et contre le
territoire arménien
quelques jours auparavant Madame Van
derlyen s'était rendu à Bakou capitale
de l'Azerbaïdjan est là elle avait signé
un accord gazier pour assurer la
sécurité des livraisons de gaz au profit
de l'Europe la concordance de ces deux
événements ne s'arrêtaient de fortuite
pour le peuple arménien alors madame la
Première ministre ma question est simple
aujourd'hui le gouvernement français se
sent-il solidaires de cet accord que
l'on peut juger indigne
et puis
l'Arménie a exprimé l'exprime
régulièrement son souhait d'obtenir des
livraisons d'armes de défense
la France accepte-t-elle aujourd'hui
d'être le fer de lance d'un dispositif
permettant à l'Arménie de disposer de
ces armes pour assurer sa protection la
protection de son peuple et de son
territoire enfin la France préside le
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
une demande prégnante de l'Arménie
d'obtenir de l'ONU la présence d'une
force d'observation et d'interposition
sur sa frontière avec l'Azerbaïdjan
pouvez-vous aujourd'hui prendre au nom
de monsieur le Président de la
République l'engagement que la France
déploiera des efforts incessants pour
que cette force d'interposition se met
en place c'est la condition de la
protection de l'Arménie et de son peuple
dont historiquement nous sommes si
proches
[Applaudissements]